bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
en procédure accélérée et en séance
publique le projet de loi autorisant la
ratification du traité de coopération
entre la france et l'afghanistan
ce traité a été lancée sous le mandat de
nicolas sarkozy et prévoit l'attribution
de 300 millions d'euros au régime
d'hamid karzaï sur cinq ans il consacre
également l'évolution du soutien de la
france à l'afghanistan qui passe d'une
dominante militaire à une dominante
civile tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle mes chers collègues l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion du projet
de loi autorisant la ratification du
traité d'amitié et de coopération entre
la république française et la république
islamiste d'afghanistan dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur laurent fabius monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs avant d'aborder le sujet
qui nous retient cet après midi je
voudrais en quelques mots très brève
puisque j'ai été interrogé par plusieurs
d'entre vous vous dire le la réaction du
gouvernement français
al'annonce de l'attentât qui a coûté la
vie notamment au ministre de la défense
syrien
nous ne savons pas encore les
circonstances exactes dans lesquelles
cette atteinte à ces produits est
évident que c'est un acte une extrême
importance
cela montre le degré de violence
auxquels on est parvenu à damas même le
terreau est dire que le gouvernement
français sans connaître les
circonstances de cet attentat a toujours
porté condamnation du terrorisme et
s'étendit compte tenu ce degré de
violence
cela rend d'autant plus nécessaire et
urgent le fait de trouver une transition
politique qui permette au peuple syrien
d'avoir un gouvernement qui exprime ses
aspirations profondes c'est la position
constante de la france que nous
défendons en ce moment même au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies et à cette
occasion je tenais à faire ces quelques
remarques lorsque nous aurons des
précisions sur les conditions de cet
attentat genou tient bien sûr à la
disposition du sénat pour un plus ample
commentaire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
gouvernement soumet aujourd'hui à votre
examen
le projet de loi autorisant la
ratification du traité
d'amitié et de coopération signé entre
la france et l'afghanistan le 27 janvier
2012 en application de l'article 53 de
la constitution
ce traité qui est signée pour une durée
de 20 ans inscrit la relation franco
afghane dans la durée et affirme
l'engagement de long terme de la france
auprès du peuple afghan comme vous le
savez nous retirons nos troupes
d'afghanistan
il est particulièrement important
précisément en ce moment que nous
adressions un signal clair de notre
volonté d'accompagner le peuple afghan
ce traité a été signé sous la précédente
majorité mais il s'inscrit dans une
trajectoire qui est concertée avec nos
alliés de soutien à la transition
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république monsieur
françois hollande
j'ajoute qu'il s'agit du premier traité
de l'histoire des relations
franco-afghanes qu'il s'agit aussi du
premier traité signé par l'afghanistan
avec un état extérieur à la région qui
sert et servira d'exemple pour d'autres
partenariats signés récemment ou en
préparation entre l'afghanistan et des
états tiers ou avec des organisations
internationales
mesdames et messieurs celles et ceux qui
sont présents cet après-midi savent que
la situation en afghanistan revêt une
importance toute particulière parce que
comme nous le savons depuis de longues
années
elle affecte la stabilité et la paix de
l'ensemble de la région et entraîne des
répercussions bien au-delà c'est
l'intérêt de la france que l'afghanistan
s'engage sur la voie de la paix de la
stabilité et c'est notre volonté je
crois d'ailleurs partagé d'y contribuer
en 2001 vous rappelez de la suite des
attentats du 11 septembre
nous nous sommes engagés nous les
français dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le terrorisme afin de priver
al-qaïda des bases afghanes à partir
desquels cette organisation opéré cela
impliquait également l'aide à la
construction d'institutions afghane qui
soit aussi solide que possible et
légitime
nous sommes un peu plus de dix ans plus
tard la situation est évidemment a
changé avec des succès et des échecs
l'intervention internationale a
contribué à transformer l'afghanistan
une constitution a été adoptée en 2004
de nouvelles institutions ont été mises
en place ben laden a été trouvé et tués
al qaïda ne bénéficient plus de refuge
sur le territoire afghan
dans ce contexte le président de la
république a pris l'engagement de
retirer notre combattants d'afghanistan
d'ici au 31 décembre 2012
je veux saluer une fois de plus et je le
fais bien sûr au nom de vous toutes et
de vous touche
l'engagement et le courage de notre
armée elle a rempli sa mission dans des
conditions périlleuses 87 soldats ils
sont morts au service de la france et je
veux le rendre aujourd'hui un hommage
notre décision de retrait a été confirmé
aux autorités afghanes qui j'en suis le
témoin alors de nombreuses conversations
avec le président karzaï l'ont approuvé
ainsi qu'à nos alliés et à nos
partenaires qui l'a aussi j'en suis le
témoin lors de la dernière réunion de
chicago ont bien compris le sens de
notre décision
cette démarche est cohérente avec le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle la transition
fixé conjointement par la communauté
internationale et par les herbes gants
sous l'égide des nations-unies le
processus prévoit comme vous le savez le
transfert progressif des responsabilités
de sécurité aux forces de sécurité
afghanes les zones transférer inclus
le district de surobi et la province de
kapissa ou plusieurs d'entre vous se
sont rendus et ont été déployées les
forces françaises
mais et là est l'essentiel par rapport
aux textes qui nous occupe cet après
midi notre retrait militaire ne signifie
nullement un abandon de l'afghanistan au
contraire s'ouvre une période nouvelle
pour notre coopération civile quels sont
les principes qui vont guider notre
action dans cette phase nouvelle qui
s'ouvre à la fois pour l'afghanistan et
pour les relations entre l'afghanistan
et la france le premier enjeu c'est de
favoriser le passage d'une société et
d'une économie de guerre à une société
et une économie de paix
c'est très ambitieux me direz vous et ça
l'est mais il faut bien mesurer capecchi
a été plongée qu'il est encore dans la
guerre pendant des années et des années
et qui doit se reconstruire pour aller
vers la paix c'est un changement
absolument massif le développement
économique et social de l'afghanistan
est la première conditions d'un retour
durable à la paix et la stabilité
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé que le
coeur de notre engagement sera une
coopération civile
c'est aussi dans cet esprit que la
france appuie un processus de paix
conduit par les afghans eux mêmes et qui
doit associer toutes les composantes de
la société afghane le gouvernement bien
sûr mais l'opposition qualifié légale et
la société civile
la réconciliation nationale devra
s'adresser à ceux des insurgés qui sont
prêts à rompre tout lien avec al-qaïda à
renoncer à la violence à respecter la
constitution et le processus devra
bénéficier du soutien des pays de la
région ce qui n'est pas le plus facile
notamment mais pas seulement du pakistan
deuxième aspect la france s'engage en
afghanistan de façon forte
il est prévu en effet que notre aide à
l'afghanistan augmente d'un volume de 50
%
pour atteindre 308 millions d'euros sur
la période 2012 2016
cette augmentation est un témoignage de
notre engagement
ce qui importe surtout c'est que l'aide
soit conduite de manière à profiter
directement à la population afghane
nous consacrons en aide à des programmes
concrets à l'image de l'extension
prochaine de l'institut médical français
que vous connaissez sans doute et qui va
disposer ainsi d'un service de santé
maternelle et néonatale
il s'agira d'une première en afghanistan
qui va contribuer à améliorer les
conditions de vie des femmes hommes
gagnent et je veux saluer à cette
occasion l'engagement de l'association
appelé la chaîne de l'espoir que
probablement plusieurs d'entre vous
connaissent qui fait un travail tout à
fait remarquable ainsi que la fondation
aga khan dans ce projet qui est
absolument exemplaire
cette aide troisième aspect ne sera pas
un chèque en blanc
elle sera conditionnée vous y reviendrez
sans doute dans la discussion à des
progrès significatifs sur la voie la
transition à la réalisation par les
afghans des engagements qu'ils ont pris
devant la communauté internationale tout
récemment lors de la conférence de tokyo
le 8 juillet à laquelle je participais
en particulier dans trois domaines clés
premier domaine ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler la bonne gouvernance la lutte
contre la corruption en particulier qui
est développée là constitue une priorité
sur laquelle nous attendons des mesures
fortes de la part du gouvernement afghan
c'est une contrepartie indispensable à
l'effort demandé à la france et nous
devons être extrêmement ferme sur ce
point les engagements pris deuxième
point en matière de démocratie devront
être tenus à plusieurs reprises les
citoyens afghans bravé les menaces et la
violence pour élire leurs représentants
et sont parfaitement en droit d'attendre
que les élections présidentielle et
parlementaires qui sont prévues en 2014
et 2015 se déroule dans des conditions
transparentes équitables et le devrons
éveillé avec nos partenaires
internationaux
troisième aspect sur lequel je veux
insister c'est l'évolution de la
situation des droits de l'homme en
particulier je devrais dire des droits
de la personne humaine des droits de la
femme et des minorités
certains progrès ont été accomplis en
matière de liberté d'expression en
particulier avec un développement
spectaculaire j'en ai été le témoin des
médias mais aussi en ce qui concerne les
droits sociaux comme l'accès à la santé
ou à l'éducation
mais ne nous faisons pas d'illusions des
motifs d'inquiétude évident demeure la
semaine dernière vous y avez été
évidemment très sensible et probablement
bouleversée comme beaucoup de gens à
travers le monde
le meurtre il n'ya pas d'autre terme
d'une femme afghane commis en public par
les talibans et de la responsable des
droits de la femme pour le gouvernement
afghan à la suite d'un attentat ciblé
dans la province du laghman rappelle à
quel point la situation des femmes là
bas demeurent souvent dramatiques
je sais combien vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous êtes
sensible à cette question je partage
totalement cette préoccupation est la
france devra faire preuve d'une
vigilance particulière s'agissant des
droits des femmes en particulier l'accès
à la justice la santé à l'éducation et
puisque tout cela commence par la
prévention des violences qui leur sont
faites
il s'agit pas seulement d'opérer des
pétitions de principe il s'agit
d'évaluer ces avancées c'est pourquoi
nous mèneront en parallèle un dialogue
avec la société civile afghane avec les
femmes afghanes avec la commission
afghane indépendante des droits de
l'homme et m'a été donné il ya de cela
quelques semaines de rencontrer un
certain nombre de ces personnalités de
ces organisations qui sont des
personnalités des organisations
absolument extraordinaire le sens du
traité qui vous est soumis pour
ratification aujourd'hui c'est de
redonner aux afghans aux autorités
gouvernementales et surtout à la
population la société civile les clés de
leur destin
tout en leur accordant un appui sur le
long terme qui doit leur permettre de
disposer des moyens d'exercer leur
souveraineté
concrètement le traité pour l'ensemble
de nos actions de coopération à bologne
avec l'afghanistan
donc il ya des engagements du côté
français il a des engagements du côté
afghan
de notre côté coopération en matière de
santé avec qui il faisait allusion
l'extension l'institut médical français
pour l'enfant afin d'en faire un centre
hospitalo universitaires généraliste et
la mise en oeuvre de projets
expérimentaux de télémédecine les
spécialistes des soins français là bas
ont une réputation extraordinaire et
nous nous sommes engagés à développer
tout sa coopération en matière
d'éducation avec les lycées peut-être ma
prononciation et l défectueuse malalai
et esteqlal et d'enseignement supérieur
avec la création à l'université
politiques de kaboul d'une école des
mines et géologie
comme vous le savez la pianiste en est
un pays où les minerais sont extrêmement
important il ya une tradition de
recherche géologique française
coopération aussi dans le domaine
agricole en particulier en matière
d'irrigation et danser malgré coll nous
soutiendrons la mise en place d'un
réseau de lycée technique agricole
afghan et la création d'un laboratoire
de contrôle de la qualité coopération
dans le domaine de la culture
s'appuyant sur nos établissements
culturels l'institut français
d'afghanistan délégation archéologique
française
nous formons des archéologues afghans
nous assurons les fouilles à bamiyan
masinac notamment ainsi que les
créations de musées afghan d'histoire
naturelle coopération pour le
développement des infrastructures
notamment l'adduction d'eau à kaboul
pour le développement du secteur minier
j'ai fait allusion
renforcement du service géologique
afghan en partenariat avec le brgm et
accroissement de nos échanges
économiques puisque je le dis si l'on
veut passer d'une économie de guerre à
une économie de paix ça doit se traduire
aussi par une présence française de nos
entreprises plus important s'agissant de
la kapissa et surobi ont été déployés la
force la fayette et notre équipe
d'experts civils
une action spécifique pour le
développement économique de ces régions
est prévue au delà de 2014 si les
populations locales le souhaite et si la
sécurité maître mot de nos personnels
est assurée afin de prolonger les
projets que nous avons déjà conduit
enfin une coopération est prévue dans
les domaines de la sécurité de la
défense non pas évidemment des troupes
combattantes mais des qu'opera en
français seront présents à l'état major
dans les écoles militaires afghanes afin
de conseiller les cadres les
instructeurs afghans il n'y aura pas de
troupes combattantes mais nous apportons
un appui à la création d'une école de
guerre afghane et d'une force de
gendarmerie
réciproquement le traité comprend des
engagements pris par l'afghanistan
envers la france l'afghanistan aux
termes de ce traité s'engage à lutter
par tous les moyens dont ils disposent
contre les menaces émanant son
territoire à l'encontre de la france où
des intérêts français
développer la coopération entre services
antiterroristes et anti drogue et là il
ya un énorme travail à faire quand on
sait ce que représente la drogue là bas
et c'est toujours considéré qu' une des
failles des mécanismes qui avaient été
mises en place c'est que je suis
peut-être aussi en disant cela mais où
ça faisait l'impasse sur l'aspect drogue
ou alors on disait il faut que les
paysans cesse de cultiver la droite mais
s'il n'y a pas des moyens alternatifs
qui leur sont proposés évidemment le
paysan ne va pas de lui-même
arrêtez de cultiver le produit qui lui
rapporte
de quoi vivent donc quelques efforts ont
été engagés
mais il faudra aller beaucoup plus loin
soutenir les institutions qui concourent
à la relation bilatérale
ça passe je vais vite par des exemptions
fiscales et douanières pour l'afd pour
nos ong impliquées dans la mise en
oeuvre du traité et cetera et cetera
promouvoir l'enseignement du français
dans le secondaire et le supérieur
donc quand même le plaisir de voir que
il y à pas mal de personnalités
notamment mais il faudrait que ça
descendre plus largement dans le reste
de la population qui parlent le français
qui ont d'ailleurs souvent fait leurs
études en france en pratique la mise en
oeuvre du programme de coopération devra
tenir compte de la capacité d'absorption
par la partie afghane des décisions des
organes de gouvernance des
établissements concernés notamment la sd
ainsi que des conditions de sécurité en
afghanistan
nous avons voulu dans ce traité éviter
un cadre institutionnel qui soit trop
pesant en plus des consultations
politiques
le traité prévoit la création de trois
commissions mixtes autonome qui doivent
se réunir une fois par an
alternativement à kaboul et à paris une
commission mixte de coopération pour le
suivi des programmes de coopération
une autre politico stratégique et une
pour la sécurité intérieure
et puis ce traité est complété par un
programme de coopération sur cinq ans
qui présente de façon plus détaillée les
projets menés sur une première période
2002 2012 pardon 2016
il a été paraphé par les ambassadeurs
français et afghan en marge de la
dernière visite à paris du président
karzaï ce traité de nous permettre de
bâtir une relation de long terme avec
l'afghanistan
sur la base des secteurs d'intervention
qui sont traditionnellement sud de la
france dans ce pays
il tient compte de notre contribution
aux actions des organisations
multilatérales qui vont rester sur place
après 2014
les nations unies naturellement mais
aussi l'union européenne et l'otan
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'aurais conclus lorsque j'aurai dit
ceci dans les années à venir alors que
l'afghanistan devra se reconstruire et
se développer ce traité d'amitié devrait
nous permettre de conserver une place
importante
et d'illustrer ce que peut-être sur par
l autre jour
à vos commissaire une puissance d'
influence comme la france les années à
venir seront d'une période tout à fait
crucial pour l'avenir de l'afghanistan
les afghans il faut faire un peu
d'histoire n'ont jamais accepté la
présence durable d'une force étrangère
sur leur sol c'est ce qui depuis
alexandre le grand jusqu'au soviétique a
donné à ce pays sa réputation je cite de
cimetière des empires le retrait des
troupes étrangères
même si les conditions en l'occurrence
était différente
le retrait des troupes étrangères est
une nécessité mais la transition n'est
pas sans risques le risque du chaos
comme au début des années 90 le rider
retour des talibans les plus extrémistes
qui avait pris le pouvoir à kaboul à la
faveur de l'anarchie nous ne devons pas
répéter les erreurs du passé en laissant
totalement à lui-même ce pays comme cela
avait été le cas après le départ des
soviétiques beaucoup de choses il faut
avoir l'humilité de le reconnaître des
prendront des voisins le pakistan mais
aussi l'inde l'iran la chine etc puisque
c'est ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement dans la diplomatie
mondiale le grand jeu la communauté
internationale doit donc rester engagés
mais sous des formes nouvelles qui soit
efficace
équipe réserve c'est un mot clé la
souveraineté de l'afghanistan
et c'est l'objet de ce traité ce sera
aussi l'objet sur la base de ce traité
nos engagements internationaux de notre
action politique aux côtés des
représentants de toutes les composantes
de la société afghane afin de contribuer
à un avenir aussi stable et apaisée que
possible pour chaque habitant de
l'afghanistan la ratification de ce
traité
quelle je l'espère vous allez maintenant
procéder est un moment important par
lequel vous les représentants du peuple
français vous adresser un message
d'amitié à la population afghane
le parlement afghan devrait ratifier ce
traité
dans les toutes prochaines semaines
l'idée est au fond à la fois très élevée
et très simple et très difficile à
atteindre mais c'est celle qui est
signifiée dans ce traité ensemble nous
devons dire que nous voulons continuer
d'agir côte à côte mais désormais
essentiellement pour une action civile
de développement et d'appui à la mise en
place d'institutions dont nous
souhaitons qu'elle soit à la fois
efficace et démocratique
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur jean louis carrère
président et rapporteur de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées
le seul président monsieur le ministre
en notre nom à tous je voudrais rendre
hommage à monsieur jean françois poncet
qui vient de nous quitter il était
membre de notre commission il y a un an
encore fils d'ambassadeur en allemagne à
l'âge de 8 ans il avait vu brûler le
reich stade ministre des affaires
étrangères président de la commission de
développement économique président du
conseil général du lot-et-garonne
premier vice président du conseil
régional d'aquitaine jean françois
poncet à occuper beaucoup de mandats et
à une carrière politique d'un très haut
niveau très active au niveau local très
active au niveau national il a marqué le
sénat par sa vision du monde
plus près de nous par sa vision du
moyen-orient mais beaucoup plus récent
puisqu'il fit un rapport mes chers
collègues très remarquée sur le
moyen-orient
à l'heure de la force nucléaire nous
gardons de lui l'image d'un homme d'état
d'une grande finesse et d'une rare
élégance
il était avant tout mesdames messieurs
un européen convaincu monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je salue la présence de
monsieur l'ambassadeur d'afghanistan un
monsieur
assad au maire qui ne soit pas choqué
par les propos que je tiendrai qui bien
qu'étant sans complaisance sont les
promos d'un ami de l'afghanistan royaume
de l'insolence l'afghanistan n'a jamais
été soumis son histoire est avant tout
celle d'une résistance énigmatique et
tenace contre tous les empire moghol
perse britanniques puis
soviétique ce magnifique pays l'un des
plus pauvres du monde livré au fléau de
la corruption du terrorisme et du trafic
de drogue
martyrisée par trois décennies de guerre
dispose mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pourtant d'atouts
incomparables pour son décollage après
la sueur aux billes en avril c'est la
province de kapissa dans laquelle 53 des
87 soldats français tombés en
afghanistan
donc je salue la mémoire ont trouvé la
mort qui a il y a tout juste deux
semaines étaient transférés aux
autorités afghanes et ainsi se tourner
une nouvelle page de son histoire avec
le traité qui nous est soumis cet après
midi oui monsieur le ministre la france
doit désormais et doit faire le choix de
concentrer ses efforts sur la
construction de la paix et la prise en
même de leur des sternes par les afghans
eux mêmes
ce projet de loi examiné en conseil des
ministres mercredi dernier
déposé en premier lieu au sénat et
débattu aujourd'hui il sera débattu
mercredi prochain à l'assemblée
nationale
pour être adopté définitivement ce 25
juillet évidemment ces délais sont très
courts
si nous avons accepté d'être ainsi
bousculé vous savez nous les sénateurs
monsieur le premier ministre même pas
trop être bousculé encore moins quand
les sénateurs des landes mais mais mais
je serais tenté de dire c'est qu'il y a
urgence et nous le comprenons urgence à
nous doter de l'instrument qui grave
dans le marbre du droit international
notre engagement dans la durée pour 20
ans aux côtés du peuple afghan que nous
ne souhaitons pas abandonner urgence
aussi à garantir la sécurité et la
stabilité de nos actions de coopération
pour l'avenir urgence enfin à mettre en
cohérence et surtout à donner une
nouvelle dynamique à tous nos
dispositifs dead à la hauteur des
besoins immenses de ce pays exsangue
après 30 ans de guerre et demain
l'enjeu est simple posons nous la
question
il s'agit ni plus ni moins de réussir la
paix l'opinion publique que nous regarde
elle ne comprendraient pas qu'on
abandonne les afghans et que nos soldats
soient morts pour rien ce traité le
principal au pays pour pouvoir
travailler efficacement à construire une
paix durable
c'est pourquoi nous l'examinons dans le
même esprit de continuité républicaine
que celui qui a poussé le nouveau
gouvernement à inscrire ce texte signé
par le précédent président de la
république à l'ordre du jour de sa
première session législative je sais ce
qu'on pourrait me dire on vous qui avez
tellement tellement critiqué c'est un de
vos premiers textes et vous inscrivez
mais bien sûr que nous l'inscrivons et
bien sûr que tout n'a pas été noir et
tout n'a pas été blanc et ce texte
mérite d'être inscrits je dois à
l'honnêteté de dire que ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas un solde de tout compte
sur le sujet de l'afghanistan
je vous remercie beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
ainsi que votre collègue ministre de la
défense d'avoir accepté de débattre avec
nous à l'automne du bilan de nos plus de
dix ans d'engagement en afghanistan
l'intervention dans ce pays décidée par
le président chirac et le premier
ministre lionel jospin avait au départ
un objectif clair celui de lutter contre
al qaïda à la suite des attentats du 11
septembre
ces finalités se sont peu à peu
transformés pour ne pas dire brouillé
aux yeux de l'opinion publique en tout
cas nous sommes nombreux pourtant à
pouvoir témoigner pour nous être rendus
aux côtés de nos soldats à plusieurs
reprises de la qualité remarquable du
travail de terrain effectué par nos
forces sur ce théâtre particulièrement
exigeant
finalement notre mission en afghanistan
aura été double comme l'a dit le
président françois hollande lors de
l'hommage aux invalides
elle aura consisté à la fois à lutter
contre le fanatisme et la haine aveugle
et à aider fraternellement un peuple a
retrouvé le chemin de sa souveraineté
les scénarios catastrophes fleurissent
ces derniers temps sur l'évolution
future de ce pays si attachant mais si
complexe scénario d'éclatement de guerre
civile de reconstitution de féodalité de
retour des talibans j'en passe je pose
une question et une seule y at il une
alternative y at il une autre voie qui
permet à l'afghanistan de sortir de son
extrême pauvreté source de tous ces mots
je dirais presque de sortir du moyen-âge
sanitaire et social dans lequel il se
trouve que celle du développement
économique à mon sens la réponse est non
la meilleure lutte contre l'insécurité
c'est de retrouver le chemin de la
croissance qui donne à chacun l'espoir
de mieux vivre la meilleure lutte contre
l'obscurantisme
c'est l'alphabétisation leur en parle
plus efficace contre l'embrigadement
dans des milices c'est un travail pour
tous dans une société plus sûre qu'est
le meilleure arme contre la pauvreté que
l'accès aux soins la reconstruction des
routes
la remise sur pied d'une agriculture
fruitière et pastorales jadis si
florissante
quelle part la france veut-elle prendre
dans cette reconstruction
c'est tout l'enjeu du traité et du
programme quinquennal qui l'accompagnent
il devrait permettre de donner un nouvel
élan à un certain nombre de projets
emblématiques comme par exemple dans le
domaine de la sécurité l'appui à la
création d'une école de guerre afghane
et d'une gendarmerie afghanes en matière
de santé la réalisation d'une deuxième
puis d'une troisième phase de l'hôpital
français pour la mère et l'enfant forme
de kaboul qui constitue un succès
éclatant
même si objectivement on peut
reconnaître monsieur boulot que son
financement incombe davantage à une ong
à la fondation aga quand qu'au
gouvernement français
l'appui à la création de lycées
techniques agricoles l'irrigation
l'apiculture la pisciculture pour offrir
aux exploitants revenus de substitution
par rapport à la culture du pavot comme
vous l'indiquiez monsieur le ministre
qui aurait la légèreté de croire que
l'on peut éradiquer cette culture sans
proposer un revenu de substitution
mais là où je m'inscris en faux c'est
lorsque les pessimistes nous indique
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de culture
agricole de substitution mesdames et
messieurs sachez que les agriculteurs en
afghanistan ne perçoivent du pavot que
des prix payés qui sont comparables aux
prix mondial de certaines céréales dont
ne croyez pas que ce sont les
agriculteurs afghans qui s'enrichissent
par la culture des pavots se sont
beaucoup plus les intermédiaires il faut
trouver des solutions pour leur
permettre d'en sortir un partenariat
disiez vous monsieur le ministre pour
former des ingénieurs des mines et des
géologues dans ce pays aux ressources
prometteuse une contribution à des
projets d'infrastructures indispensables
au développement comme l'adduction d'eau
le traité comportant faire envoler de
gouvernance destinées à la consolidation
des institutions
je voudrais d'ailleurs salué
l'engagement des assemblées
parlementaires françaises pour
construire le parlement afghan
dès 2004 des experts du sénat ont
séjourné à kaboul pour aider à la mise
en place du parlement
former les futurs fonctionnaires rédigé
le règlement est amorcé une coopération
qui ne s'est jamais ralenti et qui s'est
concrétisé encore en juin dernier par
une mission de l'assemblée nationale
le traité enfin prévoit l'octroi attendu
depuis longtemps d'exemptions fiscales
et douanières pour l' agence française
de développement et pour nos ong ou des
baux à long terme pour l'institut
français et la délégation archéologique
le traité prévoit aussi la promotion de
la langue française à tous les niveaux
d'enseignement
et la pérennisation de nos instituts
culturels
vous l'aurez compris la commission
soutient le projet de loi de
ratification qui nous est soumis mais
nous avons mesdames et messieurs mes
chers collègues troisième dérogation
forte pour ne pas dire 3 inquiétudes sur
sa mise en oeuvre
tout d'abord le montant est question qui
est son corollaire la dispersion de
l'aide française
évidemment nous ne partons pas de rien
dans les districts de la task force la
fayette
nous avons vu des champs une culture d
école qui fonctionne et des lignes
électriques rétabli au total la france
aura d'ailleurs débourser si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi 240 millions d'euros
des deux civils au cours de ces dix
dernières années avec un positionnement
de l'entr'aide bien orienté sur les
besoins vitaux santé éducation
agriculture accès à l'eau pourtant nous
sommes loin derrière l'allemagne et le
royaume uni nous avons consacrer jusqu'à
500 millions d'euros par an de surcoûts
topex à l'afghanistan qu'aux biens
pourrons nous mettre monsieur le
ministre sur la table pour donner vie au
programme quinquennal ambitieux arrêté
au début de l'année nous prévoyons 308
millions d'euros pour les cinq
prochaines années c'est un accroissement
de 50%
c'est beaucoup par rapport au montant
total de notre aide au développement
mais c'est peu par rapport aux autres je
fais confiance d'ailleurs alors à porter
sur tous les bancs quant au crédit du
développement pour veiller à ce que les
lois de finances viennent effectivement
remplir cet engagement il faut aussi
engager objectivement un effort de
rationalisation la visibilité de notre
aide souffre de la multiplicité des
circuits de financement et d guichet qui
favorise
l'éclatement le saupoudrage et l'absence
de lisibilité
enfin vous nous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que la france avait besoin
d'une diplomatie économique
on est d'accord qu en est il du
positionnement des entreprises
françaises sur les marchés afghan où
vont affluer les 16 milliards d'aidé
internationale d'ici à 2015 il ne
faudrait pas que nous assurions par
exemple la formation des géologues au
titre de la coopération pour qu'ensuite
nos amis chinois décrochent les contrats
d'exploitation des mines les entreprises
françaises peuvent se positionner sur
beaucoup de secteurs le ciment la
construction l'énergie l'eau
l'agroalimentaire
comment la diplomatie va-t-elle
accompagner et faciliter la montée en
puissance de nos entreprises
la deuxième préoccupation que je
voudrais exprimer relève de la sécurité
future de nos experts de nos ong et de
nos entreprises
en afghanistan quatre générations de
menaces se sont succédé pour ceux
cumulés au final à la guérilla
classiques sont venues se rajouter les
engins explosifs improvisés mais vous le
savez très bien
puis le recours aux bombes humaines et
récemment les attaques internes par
infiltration des forces afghanes
même si le ministre de la défense nous a
dit être résolument optimiste sur
l'évolution sécuritaire
nous sommes très préoccupés le traité
prévoit un certain nombre d' immunité en
particulier de juridiction pour les
personnes qui oeuvrent dans le cadre de
notre coopération
c'est un premier train de garantie mais
est ce suffisant
qu'en sera-t-il de même une fois les
forces combattantes retirer
l'état-major basculer sur le camp de
warehouse comme 300 hommes seulement
devront sécuriser le retrait et qu'en
sera-t-il surtout après demain je pense
aussi mes chers collègues aux experts
afghans engagés à nos côtés dans le
contexte du retrait de la coalition avec
la montée en puissance très progressive
des forces de sécurité nationales
afghanes leur autonomie encore limitée
alors que la rébellion couve toujours et
se nourrit d'un trafic de drogue qui
représente la première ressource du pays
c'est plus qu'une préoccupation c'est
une inquiétude en faire mes chers
collègues le dernier sujet de vigilance
le contrôle de la destination des fonds
et ça ne surprendra pas mon ami bernard
piras nous n'avons pas attendu le
scandale de la kabul bank pour savoir et
pour dire haut et fort que la corruption
endémique gangrène ce pays nourrit la
rébellion sape la légitimité du
gouvernement et ruinent la plupart des
efforts de la communauté internationale
pour faire arriver l'aide au plus près
des populations
notre commission a déjà par le passé
poser un diagnostic très lucide sur
l'extrême fragilité des institutions et
sur la corruption qui la gangrènent
jusqu'au plus haut niveau grâce à
l'action de la france
la conférence de tokyo s'est engagée
vers une plus grande conditionnalité de
l'aide européenne qui dépendra à
l'avenir du bon déroulement des
élections présidentielle et législatives
de 2014 et 2015 du respect des droits de
l'homme et du droit des femmes c'est la
bonne orientation
l'aide internationale doit être un
levier pour le changement et non pas une
manne pour les barons locaux comme j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de la firme et en
présence du président karzaï dans son
bureau
cela ne doit pas empêcher d'ailleurs
l'énergie ans d'un modèle afghan de
gouvernance seul susceptible de répondre
aux nécessités de ce pays qui ne sera
pas forcément calqué sur les modèles
occidentaux mais qui devra respecter un
certain nombre de lignes rouges en
matière de respect des libertés
publiques sous le bénéfice de ces trois
observations
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées a adopté le projet de loi
de ratification qui nous est soumis et
je vous invite à faire de même je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à madame michelle demessine à
monsieur le premier ministre pardon je
voulais faire et cours en particulier au
début du propos de monsieur le président
carré en associant le gouvernement de la
république à l'hommage qu'il a rendus à
juste titre votre ancien collègue
monsieur le sénateur françois poncet
c'est un homme que vous avez toutes et
tous connus qui était une grande
élégance la fois intellectuel et
physique qui a occupé
parmi les plus hauts postes de la
république qui a été comme vous l'avez
souligné le président un européen
convaincu
un homme qui était avait l'esprit à la
fois de géométrie et de finesse et dont
je crois chacun et chacune de ceux qui
l'ont connu niera qu'il a fait honneur à
la république gouvernement veut
s'associer à l'hommage que pour les
rondes et à juste titre merci monsieur
le premier ministre la parole est à
madame michelle demessine pour le groupe
crc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
aussi au nom de mon groupe m'associer à
l'hommage qui devenait de fait à jean
françois poncet c'est un homme ça vient
d'être dit qui a beaucoup marqué notre
institution et je dirais surtout les
bancs
le traité d'amitié et de coopération
entre la france et l'afghanistan que
nous sommes appelés à ratifier
aujourd'hui et généreux ambitieux et
risqué
c'est un pari sur l'avenir de ce pays
sur la capacité et la volonté de
multiples acteurs à assurer la stabilité
et la paix dans cette région
je souhaite que ce pari soit a remporté
depuis la décision du président obama
auquel nicolas sarkozy avait rapidement
emploi emboîté le pas de retirer
totalement les troupes de la force
internationale d'assistance à la
sécurité mise en oeuvre par l'otan à la
fin de l'année 2014
les principaux pays de cette coalition
menée par les états unis s'empresse de
signer des traités bilatéraux de
coopération civile avec le gouvernement
afghan
le but de ces traités et de soutenir le
développement économique du pays
en anticipant la délicate période de
transition qui existera lorsque l'armée
et la police afghanes formées par des
militaires de l'isaf seront capables
d'assumer seul la sécurité car tout le
monde sait que ce départ se traduira par
une période d'incertitude et une
contraction de la manne financière
internationale au demeurant mal répartie
au seul profit du régime en place et de
quelques seigneurs de guerre qui a été
déversé sur ce pays depuis 2001
après le retrait des troupes de l'otan
il sera évidemment nécessaire qu à un
état afghan existe réellement
en outre le développement économique et
social une gouvernance rigoureuse
et des investissements importants seront
les conditions indispensables au
maintien de l'aide publique
internationale
c'est dans cette perspective qui a été
organisée il ya quinze jours à tokyo
une conférence des pays donateurs qui
redoute un effondrement économique du
pays après le départ des troupes
étrangères et qui veulent atténuer
l'impact d'un désengagement partiel de
la communauté internationale ses
bailleurs de fonds se sont ainsi engagés
à apporter une aide civile de 16
milliards de dollars soit 13 milliards
d'euros sur la décennie 2015 2025 dont
230 millions pour notre pays par rapport
à nos capacités c'est un effort
important qu'il faudra t il faudra
utiliser à bon escient
c'est dans ce contexte que se situe le
traité franco afghan dont nous débattons
comme l'a dit l'exposé des motifs du
projet de loi de ratification le traité
marque l'évolution du soutien français
d'une dominante militaire à une
dominante civile pourtant ils
n'organisent pas seulement la future
coopération civile il comprend aussi un
important volet de coopération de
défense et de sécurité
en treize articles il donne un cadre un
ensemble de projets et d'actions sous la
forme de différents programmes
j'approuve bien entendu tout ce qui va
dans le sens du développement économique
et social de ce pays que ce soit dans
l'agriculture et le développement rural
pour atteindre l'autosuffisance
alimentaire la santé afin de réduire le
taux de mortalité infantile et
maternelle et améliorer le niveau de
formation des médecins ou bien encore
l'éducation et l'enseignement supérieur
en développant l'enseignement du
français et en soutenant les deux
lissiers que nous avons créé et qui sont
maintenant sous la responsabilité de la
république islamique à tout cela
s'ajouterait le développement des
échanges culturels et la protection du
patrimoine archéologique
enfin je n'oublie pas qu'il est prévu de
faciliter les investissements français
et les activités de nos entreprises dans
les domaines des infrastructures de
télécommunication de transport
d'irrigation de production et de
transformation des matières premières
cependant il faudrait être
particulièrement offensif et
volontariste dans ces domaines afin que
nos entreprises réussissent à se faire
une place dans un pays et sur des
marchés sur lesquels les états unis
exercent un quasi monopole
je le répète le cadre est idéal les
projets sont généreux et ambitieux en
revanche leur mise en oeuvre est
aléatoire
elle dépendra de l'importance des moyens
qui leur seront attribués mais elle se
heurtera tout autant aux incertitudes de
l'avenir est aux durs et complexe
réalité afghane
de prime abord dans un monde idéal et
harmonieux l'idée de se préoccuper du
devenir de l'afghanistan en soutenant
son développement économique après la
fin des opérations militaires pourraient
paraître indispensable et coulait de
source
le retrait accéléré de nos troupes qui
avaient déjà été amorcé par nicolas
sarkozy avec un an d'avancé sur le
calendrier fixé par les américains a été
une courageuse décision du président de
la république je voudrais ici saluer
avec force elle correspondait à une
demande de l'opinion publique française
que pour notre part nous avons été
longtemps les seuls à relayer dans ces
conditions on pourrait donc se
satisfaire de ce qui peut apparaître
comme un changement de stratégie
après les opérations militaires place au
développement économique et social
la réalité est plus complexe il faut
autant en effet ne pas être naïf mais
lucide sur les raisons qui ont poussé
les américains et le tan a organisé ce
retrait militaire ainsi que sur les
conditions dans lesquelles s effectuera
la décision de quitter militairement
l'afghanistan n'est pas fondée sur la
réalité de la situation sur le terrain
mais sur d'autres considérations
soyons pragmatiques admettons que la
présence de nos troupes
intégrée à celle de l'otan ne répondait
plus à l'objectif fixé par les
résolution initiale du conseil de
sécurité les talibans ont été chassés du
pouvoir fin 2001 est le combat contre le
terrorisme s'est transformée en lutte
contre une insurrection d'opposants au
régime en place
nous devons également admettre que
lorsque des forces armées sont présentes
sont présentes sur le territoire d'un
état souverain
pendant plus de dix ans la solution au
problème posé n'est évidemment pas
militaire fin 2014 a donc été fixée par
les états unis comme date butoir pour se
désengage pour se désengager d'un
conflit qui est l'échec de la stratégie
qu'ils ont apposé à leurs alliés
cette période coïncide rac
accessoirement avec le moment où l'armée
et la police afghanes pourraient être en
mesure de prendre le relais des troupes
de l'automne sur tout le territoire
en effet pratiquement tous les experts
nos militaires en particulier savent
qu'aujourd'hui la pléthorique armée
afghane de plus de 200 mille hommes
presque tous issus d'ethnies proche du
président karzaï n'est pas en mesure de
répondre à l'immense défi de sécurité en
vérité cette armée permet en grande
partie à assurer un emploi est revenu à
des populations très démuni son
entretien son équipement sa formation
par les militaires de l'otan'' coûte
cher et est en outre une source de
revenus non négligeable pour le pouvoir
en place les plans de formations prévues
d'ici l'échéance de 2014
la rendront sans doute un peu plus
opérationnel
mais certainement pas plus crédible dans
sa détermination à lutter contre les
ennemis du régime en place
il ne faut pas non plus se laisser
illusionner sur la réalité du
désengagement militaire des états unis
qui serait totale car à la veille de se
rendre à la conférence de tokyo
c'est à la veille de se rendre à la
conférence de tokyo que la secrétaire
d'état américaine a officialisé à kaboul
l'octroi à l'afghanistan du statut
d'allié d'allier majeure non membre de
l'otan
ce statut
qui est accordée à une quinzaine de pays
n'est pas anodin et n'a rien de
symbolique
il permet en particulier une coopération
militaire renforcée avec les états unis
dans le développement et l'achat
d'armement ajoutons à cela qu'ils ont
engagé un partenariat stratégique avec
le régime afghan dont les principales
dispositions devraient leur permettre de
conserver des implantations militaires
pendant une vingtaine d'années dans ce
pays
par ailleurs pour les plus optimistes
même si la situation sécuritaire devait
se stabiliser après le départ de la
coalition internationale
il faudrait de toute façon aider l'état
afghan
quel qu'il soit a surmonté les
difficultés qui l'attendent
elles sont nombreuses et proviennent
principalement du déficit budgétaire
prévisible pour un pays soutenu à bout
de bras par l'aide internationale
principalement américaines qui selon les
prévisions devrait diminuer de moitié
pour avoir une idée plus précise de ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler l'aide
internationale en faveur de
l'afghanistan
il faut savoir que la conférence de
tokyo a estimé que plus de la moitié du
trou budgétaire à venir proviendraient
des dépenses de sécurité pour l'armée et
la police afghanes
évalué à 4 milliards les pays de l'otan
devraient le prendre en charge à hauteur
de 3,6 milliards de dollars tandis que
les 3,7 milliards de déficit civile
devrait en principe être assumée par les
états donateurs participants à la
conférence de tokyo
on peut ainsi légitimement s'interroger
sur la réalité du changement de
stratégie qui serait en cours il
faudrait également tirer les
enseignements sur la façon dont cette
aide a été distribuée est utilisée afin
d'être plus exigeants en ce qui concerne
la gouvernance du pays aidés car cette
manne financière a surtout contribué à
alimenter une bulle artificielle qui a
enrichi une chaîne de sous traitants
afghans et étrangers tandis que la
population n'ont bénéficié que de
manière résiduelle les retombées locales
de 7 à 6 ans sont toujours très limité
selon les estimations de la banque
mondiale sur chaque dollar dépensé seuls
20 à 25 % restent en afghanistan
il faut aussi déplorer que le climat
d'incertitude qui s'annonce exacerbe une
corruption déjà endémique les principaux
acteurs en sont des gros des groupes
d'intérêts à vide d'accaparer les
ressources encore disponibles et de les
mettre à l'abri à l'étranger en
particulier à dubaï dont nous
reparlerons certainement dans le débat
qui succédera à celui ci pour apprécier
le bien fondé la pertinence et
l'efficacité des mesures contenues dans
le traité qui nous est soumis il faut
donc jugés en fonction des critères
ayant trait à la qualité de l'aide et à
la façon dont elle est répartie sur
place or de ce point de vue je n'ai pas
le sentiment que les dispositions de ce
traité qui je le rappelle a été négocié
par le précédent gouvernement avec le
régime du président karzaï soit
suffisamment exigeante en particulier
celles qui visent à prévenir la
corruption ambiante et garantir une
bonne gouvernance sont insuffisantes
elles sont pourtant essentielles pour
assurer une juste répartition de l'aide
auprès de la population afghane
elle se limite à la mise en place d'une
commission mixte chargée de suivre la
lutte contre les trafics illégaux et à
une assistance assistance technique et
opérationnel pour renforcer la lutte
contre la criminalité organisée et les
trafics de stupéfiants et d'êtres
humains mais si les personnels sont peu
fiables est incompétent l'assistance
risquent d'être inefficaces ce point
essentiel ne serait cependant masqué qui
lie à à mettre sur pied une véritable
administration car sinon les milliards
de dollars dettes seront gaspillés et
nous pourront pas combler rapidement le
manque de fonctionnaires afghans formés
ni l'absence institutions fonctionnelles
et viable notamment au niveau local
je suis sceptique malgré toutes nos
qualités tout sur les moyens financiers
qui seront réellement en mesure de
consacrer à la formation des cadres
d'une administration centrale et
territoriale embryonnaires ainsi que
selon l'ampleur de notre participation à
la formation des professeurs de droit
des universités afghane
en effet face à l'affluence américaine
et anglo saxon prépondérante nos nos
efforts pour important qu'ils soient
sont pourtant dérisoire
au total je suis convaincu que la
stabilité de l'afghanistan passe
obligatoirement par son développement
économique et social et que ce sont les
populations afghanes qui doivent
prioritairement en bénéficier
c'est certainement la meilleure façon de
se débarrasser des deux fléaux majeurs
qui gangrène ce pays
le terrorisme et le narcotrafic le
retour à la suite de la sécurité
dépendra donc du niveau de l'effort
national et international et des
conditions dans lesquelles il sera
entrepris pour répondre aux vrais
besoins de développement d'une façon
mais d'une façon générale sur le fond
une solution durable du conflit afghan
ne peut être que politique et
diplomatique
on ne peut le traiter en dehors du
contexte régional et international car
tout est lié
il faut réintégrer pleinement l'onu dans
la résolution de ce conflit
elle doit reprendre le mandat qu'elle
avait confiée à l'isaf
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons que la
france en sa qualité de membre permanent
du conseil de sécurité prenne
l'initiative de proposer l'organisation
d'une conférence régionale pour définir
précisément les conditions d'une paix
négociée et durable en afghanistan en
afghanistan
celle ci devrait réunir des voisins
immédiats comme l'iran ou le pakistan
mais aussi lane
la chine la russie la turquie et bien
sûr toute la diversité des différentes
composantes du peuple afghan pour être
efficace cette conférence pourrait être
parrainée par des représentants des
états unis et de l'union européenne afin
que l'eau et murs deviennent ainsi le
principal acteur du rétablissement de la
paix de la sécurité
il reviendra ensuite au conseil de
sécurité de garantir les conclusions de
cette conférence régionale
enfin pour que l'onu reprenne
complètement la main sur la résolution
de cette crise il serait né sait si
nécessaire de définir un nouveau mandat
sur la base des conclusions de cette
conférence axée sur les conditions de la
reconstruction et du développement de ce
pays ayant maintenant l'ambition de
créer un nouveau cadre multilatéral pour
résoudre ce conflit
même si elles sont présentées
sous un jour nouveau ne suivons pas les
démarches anciennes qui ont échoué au
lieu de s'engager aussi rapidement du
négoce dans une coopération incertaine
et qui risque d'être inefficace au
regard des objectifs généreux fixé dans
ce texte n'aurait-il pas été préférable
d'être plus exigeants en matière de
gouvernance et pourquoi pas d'en
renégocier certains aspects en ce sens
ceci étant malgré tout nos réserves et
toutes les insuffisances de ce traité
nous voulons donner une chance à la paix
et nous ne nous y opposerons pas nous ne
souhaitons pas jouer les cassandre nie
avoir une attitude négative
nous voulons simplement attirer
l'attention sur certains aspects
négatifs et être vigilant sur les
risques que comporte ce texte
en conséquence le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen s'abstiendra sur
ce projet de loi de ratification datex
entre la france et l'afghanistan
merci madame la parole est à monsieur
jean pierre plancade pour le groupe
rds
monsieur le président mais c'est le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
la france a une longue histoire de
coopération avec ce pays puisqu'elle
remonte à 1922 et les premiers contacts
des formaliser la création de la
délégation archéologique française en
afghanistan
puis à 22 3 avec la création du lycée
français pour garçons voilà aujourd'hui
le rdse se réjouit de ce traité certes
il a été préparé par la majorité
l'ancienne majorité aujourd'hui monsieur
le premier ministre vous le reprenez
votre compte et vous avez raison
les membres du rds et moi-même
apporterons notre soutien à ce projet de
loi qui contribuera comme ça a été dit à
développer les liens d'amitié et de paix
qui unissent les peuples français et
afghans un grand projet de développement
économique
finalement c'est une grande idée la paix
par le commerce la paix par l'activité
économique
et je crois qu'il est important que on
s'engage rapidement dans cette voie même
si même si des difficultés ont été
évoquées par plusieurs de mes collègues
fortement par mon ami jean louis carrère
et par d'autres hommes de bessines
également mais moi je suis un de ceux
qui pensent comme jean jaurès que la
tristesse et réactionnaire disait-il
seule la joie et républicaine et je suis
un vrai républicain et c'est pour ça que
je crois dans ce traité et j'y crois
avec beaucoup beaucoup de conviction -
uti et créer le premier groupe d'étude
sur l'afghanistan
et d'ailleurs je dois dire que la france
la france a par delà son passé a déjà
fait beaucoup
indépendamment de ces êtres de deux
interventions militaires que nous avons
fait
les ong sont présentes depuis longtemps
et je crois qu'elles connaissent bien la
situation
je vois qu'on avait été pas 10 millions
d'euros à la relance de la culture du
coton dans les provinces de kunduz et de
bach bon l'inauguration 2006 de
l'institut médical français pour
l'enfant de kaboul
ak vous certes financé par des ong mais
l'extension sera assurée par un prêt de
l'afd le sénat bien plus modestement en
son temps tout début de l'arrivée dans
l'île karzaï a participé à ma demande
d'ailleurs à la création d'un collège
grâce à l'aide apportée par messieurs
poncelet et lambert alors président du
sénat et de la commission des finances
qui a permis d'ailleurs d'accueillir
1200 élèves dont 400 filles avec une
classe mixte
je ne doute pas que ce traité va
permettre des actions beaucoup plus
conséquente est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus importante
bien sûr monsieur le ministre nous
n'irons pas la crise qui frappe notre
pays et qui rend les choses qui vont
rendre les choses certainement plus
difficile
pour mémoire en 2005 au g8 de gleneagles
nous avions pris l'engagement de
consacrer 0 7% du pib à l'aide publique
au développement
elle est aujourd'hui que de 0 5% au-delà
des aspects assez classique de
coopération que je viens d'évoquer le
traité du 27 janvier comporte aussi une
dimension sécuritaire alors il est
important aussi d'accompagner le
processus de transition pour que
l'ensemble des responsabilités de
sécurité incombe d'ici 2014 autorités
afghanes
conformément à ce qui a été décidé au
sommet de l'otan qui s'est déroulé à
lisbonne en 2010
ce volume je volais du traité me conduit
naturellement à évoquer la question de
l'engagement militaire de la france en
cours dans ce pays depuis 2001 et qui
rappelons le a malheureusement coûté la
vie
à 87 de nos soldats qui bien entendu
nous rendons hommage le brillant la
république a décidé d'avancer à 2012 le
retrait des troupes françaises
d'afghanistan
il l'a confirmé au sommet de chicago
nous avions des objectifs celui de radis
qu'ils les camps d'al qaïda de renverser
le pouvoir taleb soutien de
l'organisation terroriste bien connu
grâce au courage au sens du devoir de
nos soldats et de tous ceux de la
coalition nous avons franchi cette étape
en effet l'armée française a contribué à
chasser les talibans de kaboul avec
d'autres naturellement al qaïda est
évacuée vous l'avez rappelé a été
évacuées d'afghanistan
le pays s'est doté d'une constitution
la france de son côté a créé un pôle de
relative stabilité dans la province de
kapisa dans le district de surobi
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
limitez rend si on t'avait poursuivront
après le retrait les unités combattantes
la formation des officiers afghans
j'espère que le gouvernement afghan
conservera les bénéfices de ces actions
quoi qu'il en soit la présence militaire
française est désormais inappropriée
dans son format actuel et nous avons eu
raison d'avancer la date de leur taux de
leurs prêts l'émission initiale étant
accomplie laisser tous les soldats
français sur le terrain soit 3500 hommes
pourrait placer notre pays dans la
posture d'un occupant
ce sont donc deux mille soldats français
qui devrait quitter cette terre d'asie
centrale à la fin de l'année dans des
conditions qui restent à définir
conditions préoccupantes en matière de
sécurité pour leurs traits aux troupes
on s'interroge pourtant compter sur
l'armée nationale afghane quel rôle peut
jouer le pakistan maintenant que le port
de karachi ville d'être ouvert à nouveau
à l'otan mes chers collègues hier la
france s'est engagée sans état d'âme sur
le terrain afghan pour tenter de
stabiliser ce pays qui porte les germes
de notre propre déstabilisation les
attentats les enlèvements d'occidentaux
jusqu'à la ferme et rats ont
dramatiquement illustrer le danger du
maintien de foyers terroristes ici ou
ailleurs
aujourd'hui nous nous allons quitter ce
pays sans toutefois l'abandonner
cet objectif du traité d'amitié de
coopération de vienne 7 janvier 2012
que nous nous apprêtons à adopter mais
avant de conclure monsieur le ministre
je dois dire que j'ai malgré tout un
sentiment partagé sur l'action sur notre
action en afghanistan
quand je dis notre action je parle pas
de la france en particulier je parle
évidemment de
des pays occidentaux je ne sais pas si
c'est un échec ou un succès alors je me
dis ce n'est ni complètement la nie
complètement l'autre certes nous avons
chassé les talibans certes nous avons
donné à ce pays nous avons contribué à
donner une constitution à ce pays
certes nous avons posé les bases les
germes d'une démocratie on met ce qui
m'interroge c'est que quand nous quand
nous sommes arrivés en afghanistan il ya
dix ans nous avons été accueillis en
libérateurs et aujourd'hui on sent bien
que la population afghane et les
autorités organes nous demande de partir
alors que s'est il passé entre temps
quel comportement avant noël nous qui
voulions apporter la paix la démocratie
la liberté le développement économique
quel comportement avant nos rues et je
pense que la communauté internationale
doit s'interroger
et puis évidemment mais ça a été dit par
d'autres ce pays est il vraiment
complètement stabilité la proximité du
pakistan
le rôle des services spéciaux de l'isie
nous laisse un peu perplexe nous dire
aussi que ce pays et vous l'avez dit ne
fera pas la paix tout seul sans le
pakistan sans l'inde sans la chine
certainement et sans l'iran non plus je
pense aussi à cet effort massif d'argent
les 300 millions d'euros français mais
globalement les 15,16 milliards de
dollars que l'on envisage de déverser
sur ce pays
dans quelles conditions seront inversés
pourquoi faire pour king quand on
connaît le le le le niveau de corruption
et ça a été dit par président carrère
tout à l'heure le niveau de corruption
de ce pays
voilà autant de questions que je me pose
mais lucidement parce que je pense que
on peut toujours se faire plaisir mais
je crois qu'il est important de marché
avec la vérité à côté de soi voilà alors
nous allons passer du clairement d'une
aide militaire à une aide civile
c'est dans le droit fil de ce qui a
toujours guidé une une part de notre
politique étrangère
au cours de ces dernières années
construire la paix d'ailleurs j'ai en
mémoire un discours de françois
mitterrand en 1984 qui s'adressant au
corps diplomatique
un peu plus élargie nous avons dix et il
nous n'avons pas un seul soldat hors de
nos frontières
qu'il ait d'autres missions que de
préserver des vies humaines que de
contribuer à rétablir des équilibres et
si ces pays par la suite désir notre
contribution pacifique à leur
développement
il leur suffira de nous demander bien
c'est actuellement ce qui est en train
de se passer
je m'inscris donc dans ses propos de
l'ancien président république la france
à participer au rétablissement d'un
certain équilibre en afghanistan ce pays
nous demandent maintenant de contribuer
à son relèvement économique et sociale
alors construisons la paix et l'adoption
du projet de loi que vous allez
présenter monsieur le ministre participe
de cette démarche c'est pourquoi le rdse
approuvera ce projet généreux et
ambitieux merci mon cher collègue dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur christian cambon
pour le groupe ump
tueur est le sien
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais bien sûr à cet instant et au
nom du groupe ump associé celui ci à
l'hommage que notre président jean louis
carrère et vous monsieur le premier
ministre avait tenu il ya quelques
instants à l'occasion triste
malheureusement du décès de la diva de
la disparition de notre ancien collègue
jean françois poncet il a été rappelé
ici la personnalité particulièrement
attachante de jean françois poncet qui
faisait preuve à la fois d'une immense
courtoisie d'une très grande largeur
d'esprit et je veux dire pour avoir le
souvenir d'être arrivé à la commission
des affaires étrangères et d'avoir pu
bénéficier comme nombre d'entre vous de
son expérience d'ancien ministre
le grand commis de l'état et de profiter
de ces analyses toujours pertinentes et
exigeante
nous avons pu véritablement apprécier ce
grand parlementaire dont nous allons
garder le souvenir et qui a donné me
semble-t-il une très belle image de
notre haute assemblée monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues le
gouvernement a choisi d'inscrire à
l'ordre du jour de sa première session
législative le traité d'amitié et de
coopération entre la france et
l'afghanistan signé le 27 janvier
dernier par le président karzaï et le
président sarkozy
nous ne pouvons que nous féliciter de
cette initiative qui porte en elle
plusieurs symboles symbole tout d'abord
de la continuité de l'état
la parole et la signature de la france
sont respectées au delà des changements
politiques que nous venons de connaître
c'est là me semble-t-il l'expression
d'un état démocratique
symbole aussi de réalisme
il semble bien loin le temps de la
campagne électorale ou aux amis de
gauche n'avait pas assez d'eux n'avait
pas de mots assez durs pour qualifier la
politique extérieure de la france sous
le précédent quinquennat
force est de constater aujourd'hui que
le principe de réalité l'emportent loin
d'abaisser la france sur la scène
internationale
ce traité prouve s'il en était encore
besoin que le président sarkozy avait
fait depuis longtemps
l'exact analyse de ce conflit persuadé
que la réponse militaire aux actions
terroristes des talibans et est certes
nécessaire mais insuffisante
l'ancien président a d'abord décidé
d'anticiper à la fin 2013
le retour de notre contingent mais il
avait aussi voulu ce traité pour engager
la france aux côtés de l'afghanistan sur
la voie du développement et de la paix
c'est en effet nous le savons tous la
seule réponse d'avenir pour que les
populations reprenne en main leur destin
et tourne enfin le dos à la pauvreté et
son corollaire l'extrémisme vous
demander monsieur le premier ministre
vous demandez aujourd'hui au parlement
la ratification de ce traité nous
prenons acte de cette bonne décision et
nous vous apporterons notre soutien
telle est bien en effet l'autre symbole
que nous souhaitons porter aujourd'hui
celui d'une opposition responsable à
l'image du rôle que nous tentons de
jouer à l'invitation de notre président
le président carrère que je souhaite
saluer ici pour la qualité du travail
que nous effectuons ensemble en
commission des affaires étrangères
notre position est fidèle à ses
convictions
elle est fidèle à ses engagements mais
notre position sera aussi vous
accompagner et vous soutenir toutes les
fois où vous défendrait les intérêts
supérieurs du pays et où vos projets
iront dans la bonne direction
nous avons malheureusement trop vécu par
le passé
le spectacle parfois affligeant d'une
opposition de gauche
enfermé dans ses propres certitudes pour
ne pas choisir aujourd'hui une autre
voie plus conforme aux intérêts de la
france et à l'idée que nous avons du
débat parlementaire
ce traité mes chers collègues avec ce
traité mérite amplement d'être ratifié
car il apporte une réponse concrète
diverses et réaliste au formidable
besoins de développement
qu'attend le peuple afghan la france n'a
cessé en 90 ans de renforcer ses
relations amicales avec ce pays
la coopération mise en place a permis la
création de lycées le premier ministre a
rappelé l'instauration de d'une action
en faveur de l'archéologie et des
soutiens humanitaire mise en oeuvre dès
nous avons su mettre durant toutes ces
années le savoir faire français au
service des populations afghanes
aujourd'hui le développement de
l'afghanistan est un enjeu crucial pour
l'avenir de la région et l'éradication
des groupes d'islamistes radicaux
c'est en ce sens que la france souhaite
accroître son engagement par le biais de
ce traité qui scelle notre coopération
pour les 20 années à venir
cet acte solennel établit ainsi les
nouvelles relations avec l'afghanistan
afin que notre aves investissements dans
cette région du monde particulièrement
troublé perdure au delà du retrait de
nos troupes
par ce traité la france s'engage aux
côtés des forces gouvernementales pour
une coopération bilatérale notamment en
matière d'agriculteurs d'agriculture
d'éducation de lutte contre la drogue de
combat en faveur de la santé mais aussi
pour une meilleure gouvernance et même
si cela a été rappelé aussi même s'il
est illusoire et vain de tenter
d'imposer un système démocratique
occidental un pays de culture tribale et
ancestrale très différentes
notre effort doit néanmoins porter sur
la gouvernance de cet état qu'il
s'agisse de la condition des femmes
le premier ministre a rappelé
l'effroyable fait divers entre
guillemets le 11 juillet dernier où une
femme a été assassinée en public pour
adultère qu'il s'agisse de l'accès pour
tous à l'éducation
nous désirons donner aux nouvelles
autorités toute l'assise nécessaire pour
respecter
l'état de droit en cela le traité
prévoit une collaboration accrue entre
nos pays dans le domaine des
institutions
néanmoins si ces bus sont louables de
nombreuses inquiétudes subsistent elles
ont été évoqués sur plusieurs bancs de
la haute assemblée quant à la mise en
oeuvre de ce traité la première
inquiétude s'attache au coût financier
des cinq prochaines années
sur ces cinq années 308 millions de
crédits dettes civile aux développements
sont prévus
suite à la conférence de tokyo c'est une
somme considérable monsieur le ministre
50 millions d'euros par an pour un pays
alors qu'en moyenne la france consacre
aux quatorze pays les plus pauvres
prioritaires de la coopération à peine
plus de 10 millions par an et par pays
alors au moment où les difficultés
budgétaires ne cessent de s'accumuler
pour la france au point que votre
gouvernement annonce ces jours ci un
vaste plan de rigueur à l'attention à
l'intention de tous les français
comment allez-vous pouvoir tenir ses
engagements financiers
sachez que nous serons bien évidemment
attentifs à la réponse que vous nous
apporterez sur ce point notre seconde
crainte est relative à la sécurité de
nos militaires et de nos coopérants
l'état français a une responsabilité à
l'égard de nos militaires et coopérants
et bien évidemment une responsabilité en
termes de sécurité
le nouveau président de la république a
décidé d'accélérer le retrait logistique
de nos troupes nous en prenons acte
c'était annoncé pendant la campagne nous
craignons néanmoins que ce retrait se
fasse dans la précipitation
ces décisions hâtives n'expose tel
panneau troupes à des risques
d'attentats et d'agression comme
s'évertue à le souligner de nombreux
experts nous avons également la
préoccupation de la sécurité des
personnels dédiés à la coopération
civile
comme vous le savez les groupes
terroristes n'ont aucun scrupule à s'en
prendre à la sécurité et à la vie des
français engagés dans les organisations
non gouvernementales
l'exemple du sahel est hélas frappant
sur ce point
certes le traiter leurs garanties
d immunité de juridiction et sécurise
les conditions d'intervention de
l'agencé française de développement
présentes à kaboul depuis des années et
que je souhaite saluer ici c'est une
bonne chose
elle était attendue depuis longtemps
mais nous demeurons inquiet quant à
savoir si les troupes qui resteront sur
place avec des missions précises seront
suffisantes pour assurer leur sécurité
notre vigilance se porte aussi sur
l'efficacité de notre aide
même si d'indéniables progrès ont été
réalisés et ce principalement en matière
d'infrastructures et de développement
économiques
l'afghanistan reste frappé par la
corruption
les rivalités idéologiques et le
commerce institutionnalisée de la drogue
ce sont autant d'obstacles au
redressement durable et autonome de ce
pays
nos inquiétudes sont notamment très
forte sur la persistance au sein des
forces afghanes d'infiltration de
rebelles talibans une appréhension une
appréhension fondées qui plus est sur le
fait qu'un retour des talibans au
pouvoir favoriserait dans les pays
voisins et notamment au pakistan
la montée d'islamistes radicaux pour que
notre aide soit efficiente
votre action diplomatique monsieur le
premier ministre devra donc privilégié
l'implication des grandes puissances
voisines baptiste en iran chine et
russie
sans le concours desquels la paix ne
reviendra pas de même notre dispositif d
aide au développement se doit d'être le
plus efficace possible
malheureusement dans un de ses récents
rapports la cour des comptes vient de
dénoncer son éclatement l'éclatement de
cette aide au développement et les faits
de saupoudrage et la cour pointe
directement le cas de l'afghanistan où
il semble même que nous atteignons des
sommets d'irréalisme on ajoute la
dispersion à la pénurie pour achever
doter toutes les ibilité à notre action
il faut impérativement et ce sont les
deux rapporteurs mon ami jean claude
peyronnet moi même qui le rappelons ici
il faut impérativement rationaliser
notre système est évaluée de façon
régulière les actions menées
si nous voulons être efficaces et je
tiens ici à saluer
l'action menée en ce sens par notre
collègue henri de raincourt
lorsqu'il exerçait les fonctions de
ministre de la coopération son
successeur pascal canfin qui a eu
l'élégance et la courtoisie de nous
recevoir et je souhaite le saluer a dit
qu'il faisait de l'évaluation de la
transparence et de la lutte contre la
corruption une priorité de la
coopération
c'est un taré c'est un terrain
d'application tout trouvé en afghanistan
nous l'aiderons bien évidemment dans ce
sens
alors le gouvernement le premier
ministre devra relever trois défis pour
réussir à rendre ce traité utile et
productif le premier d'entre eux sera la
gouvernance dans un pays où la
corruption endémique empêche toute
avancée le risque est fort que l'aide
internationale se perdent dans les
sables mouvants du népotisme et de la
concussion qui gangrène tout l'appareil
d'état
aussi monsieur le président quel
conditionnalité de notre aide
comptez vous imposer des élections
doivent se tenir en 2014 et 2015
pensez vous pouvoir influer sur l'action
du gouvernement afghan pour que des
réformes profondes favorise la sincérité
du scrutin et endiguer la corruption
autre défi il vous fera faire émerger
des actes il nous faudra faire émerger
des activités économique diversifié il
s'agit de développer les activités de
substitution par rapport à la culture du
pavot et je partage l'analyse de notre
président carrère sur l'optimisme qui
convient d'avoir vis-à-vis de ceux de ce
défi des filles au demeurant fort
difficile si l'on considère que le
chiffre d'affaires tiré de cette
agriculture se situe selon les intérêts
les instances internationales entre 1 et
4 milliards de dollars
mais jean louis carrère a su rappeler
que ce n'était pas un quatre milliards
de dollars qui allaient dans la poche
les afghans néanmoins le traité a vu
juste en tentant d'apporter un revenu
alternatif aux exploitants agricoles en
faisant du développement agricole
une de ces pierres angulaires
pour le premier pays producteur d'opium
et d'héroïne
le traité a pris toutes les bonnes
options mises en culture du coton
irrigation mécanisation électrification
élevage enseignement agricole les jalons
sont les posent les jalons sont posés
saurez-vous saurons-nous les exploiter
et nous aurons besoin de toute la
compétence de nos coopérants pour y
parvenir
vous devrez monsieur le premier ni ce
savoir les soutenir et leur donner les
moyens d'agir défi autres l'amélioration
des conditions de vie et la protection
des libertés qui doivent être constant
durant cette période du traité et bien
au delà accès aux soins accès à
l'éducation préservation du patrimoine
architectural et culturel
le traité là encore ouvre la voie et
trace la route
les moyens suivront ils il ne faudrait
pas que les grandes réalisations comme
le l'hôpital mère-enfant de kaboul ne
cache la triste réalité d'un délabrement
d un style des infrastructures
sanitaires dans les campagnes la
situation des saints et celle des
enfants afghans sera notre curseur pour
mesurer les progrès accomplis
enfin il n'est pas interdit d'espérer
qu'avec un tel effort de coopération
les entreprises françaises puisse
légitimement accéder aux marchés de
reconstruction et de développement de
l'afghanistan
trop souvent hélas nous le savons la
france consent des efforts de
coopération importants mais se voit
supplanté par bien d'autres pays
lorsqu'il s'agit de bénéficier dans ses
intérêts de du fruit de la
reconstruction et donc il conviendra de
préserver les intérêts de la france et
ceux de nos entreprises
à cet égard l'exemple d'haïti est riche
en enseignements
vous nous préciser monsieur le ministre
je vous pose ce que vous comptez faire
en ce sens mes chers collègues le 27
janvier dernier la france s'est
solennellement engagé dans une nouvelle
dynamique aux côtés du peuple afghan
il revient désormais à votre
gouvernement de faire fructifier les
promesses d aide au développement
contenu dans ce traité nous sommes là
pour vous accompagner dans un esprit
constructif mais vous le comprendrez
tout aussi particulièrement vigilent
mes chers collègues la france a apporté
une contribution majeure à la lutte
contre le terrorisme en afghanistan
3500 de nos soldats qui ont servi avec
courage et avec abnégation mais plus
encore 87 d'entre eux y ont fait le
sacrifice de leur vie et nous leur
rendons ici hommage
une fois de plus de façon unanime mais
ces sacrifices ne doivent pas rester
vains il faut que ces soldats sache il
faut que les familles de nos disparus
sache que le prix immense qu'ils ont
payé permettra un jour à l'afghanistan
de vivre en paix et en prospérité
ce jour là ce jour là seulement le don
de leur vie aura enfin trouvé un sens je
vomis merci mon cher collègue dans la
suite de la discussion la parole est à
monsieur aymeri de montesquiou pour le
groupe uc r
fabien
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues jean
françois-poncet homme d'état du plus
haut niveau et est un ami je lui exprime
au nom de notre groupe
notre respect amitié et coopération
amitié illustrant la longue tradition
des relations franco-afghanes est
magnifiée par la fraternité les armes
coopération elle ne fut pas à la hauteur
des besoins de ce pays
le sera t-elle désormais lorsqu'on
aborde le sujet de l'afghanistan
on éprouve une certaine gêne et le
sentiment d'un immense gâchis
nous avons fêté le dernier 14 juillet
dans la kapisa
nous allons bart partir avec la blessure
d'un échec douloureux alors que 87 de
nos soldats ont donné leur vie pour
combattre un mouvement terroriste et
lutter pour les droits de l'homme et
comme nous tous je le rends hommage
nous allons partir il n'y avait sans
doute pas d'alternative en dépit de
l'effort militaire considérable réalisé
l'afghanistan risque de devenir la base
terroriste que veulent constituer les
talibans avatar d'al qaïda
vous me semblez optimiste monsieur le
ministre lorsque vous nous dites qu al
qaïda a été éradiquée c'est le
commandant massoud un prisonnier chef
salem m'affirmait leur volonté de
transformer les états d'asie centrale
on émirats dell annonce du retrait les
prémices de feu jihad se sont manifestés
par des attentats suicide au kazakhstan
pays où se côtoyaient paisiblement
toutes les religions et des dizaines de
nationalités pour que cette paix perdure
il est essentiel d'intensifier
considérablement la coopération
militaire avec les pays d'asie centrale
craignons les métastases du
fondamentalisme craignons la gangrène de
la corruption craignons les trafics de
drogue dans cette région cruciale pour
la paix et la sécurité
trait d'union entre l'asie et l'europe
et recelant de puissantes réserves en
hydrocarbures et minéraux nos standards
occidentaux ne peuvent être imposées
nous avons pu constater les résultats
très négatif de cet objectif
l'arrogance et la condescendance
occidentales ont profondément blessé
le peuple afghan certains ont osé
assimilée à une croisade notre action
contre le terrorisme
notre présence militaire a été perçu
comme une force d'occupation et à
rapprocher les nationalistes des
talibans pourtant se résigner au
pessimisme est stérile et 6 11 années de
présence internationale ne peuvent se
conclure par la prophétie du grand poète
afghan saïd des road in majou écrivant
demain sera l'enfer comparé à
aujourd'hui
néanmoins prenons garde espérons et
agissons pour que la coopération
internationales régionales et
bilatérales en effervescence depuis le
lancement du processus d'istanbul en
novembre dernier
contribuer à changer le contexte c'est
le sens de ce projet de loi qui met en
place une véritable coopération civile
avec l'afghanistan au moment de la
transition
il dépoussière nos liens bilatéraux mais
ne répétons pas les
erreurs passées apportons les services
de base l'eau l'électricité province
après province village après village
internet aussi pour que les jeunes
afghans intègre pleinement la jeunesse
mondiale
ces actions coûteront beaucoup moins
cher que la guerre et les résultats en
seront infiniment meilleur mais surtout
surveillons de près l'utilisation des
fonds j'ai vu des ong construire avec ou
dix fois moins élevé les mêmes
habitations que d'autres ce gâchis a
exaspéré les populations éradiquons le
pavot parler culture subventionnée pour
tarir le trésor de guerre des chefs
une interrogation pourquoi un traité
d'amitié et de coopération
alors que l'allemagne les etats-unis
l'australie et la turquie ont signé avec
l'afghanistan
des partenariats stratégiques
monsieur le ministre délégué à la
coopération s'est rendu à kaboul en juin
quelle est l'implication réelle de notre
pays dans le processus d'istanbul
y aura-t-il un nouveau représentant
spécial pour l'afghanistan pour
renforcer notre présence nous avons
besoin d'alliances régional et de
prendre enfin conscience de la réalité
très forte d'un monde inde au persan
dans cet esprit le processus d'istanbul
la conférence de kaboul coeur de l'asie
en juin la conférence de tokyo il y a
dix jours met en place une collaboration
nouvelle est étroite entre l'afghanistan
et l'ensemble de la région
cette indispensable car seul efficace
mais cette mesure de confiance sont
pilotés chacune par un état de la région
mais si le pakistan le kazakhstan
coordonne la gestion des catastrophes
les émirats arabes unis organisent la
lutte contre le terrorisme
la russie l'azerbaïdjan celle contre la
drogue
le turkménistan et l'azerbaïdjan
articule les infrastructures régionales
l'un d'eux met en place les plans
commerciaux l'iran prend en charge
d'éducation l'iran est incontournable il
n'existe aucune solution sans lui
n'oublions pas que l'iran et
l'afghanistan non former qu'un seul pays
n'oublions pas que beaucoup de pays de
la région ont de bonnes relations avec
lui
l'iran fera tout pour éviter un bastion
salafistes sur son plan est
nous avons là un intérêt majeur en
commun les ennemis de nos ennemis
peuvent devenir peut-être pas encore des
amis mais dès maintenant des partenaires
c'est une opportunité unique de
réintégrer l'iran dans la coopération
internationale
ce serait irresponsable
ce serait une faute grave de ne pas
saisir cette occasion pour le faire
participer au processus de paix au
moyen-orient où il joue un rôle capital
je vous a ajouté qu'une intervention
d'israël contre l'iran serait très lourd
de conséquences elle provoquerait
l'embrasement général des peuples
musulmans contre l'occident à civile et
un soutient israël autres pays essentiel
l'inde
elle appuiera tout gouvernement qui
luttera contre le fondamentalisme
islamiste
mais pour que cet appui ne soit pas
qu'un moyen de contrer le pakistan et
pour amener ces derniers à lutter
ouvertement contre les talibans il faut
que la communauté internationale incite
l'inde a trouvé une solution plus
équilibrée au cachemire
les prix les et centrale je le répète
sont très inquiets ils doivent contenir
les mouvements islamistes qui commence à
les ébranlé par des attentats
terroristes
le tadjikistan a connu une guerre
civile entre islamistes et ancien
communiste dans les années 90
l'ouzbékistan pays le plus peuplé
connaît deux partis islamistes ds ou le
tahrir basé à londres et le mouvement
islamique d'ouzbékistan qui prône
l'établissement du califat et la lutte
armée
il partage avec ses voisins kirghizes
tadjikes la vallée du fergana plaque
tournante de nombreux trafics et
poudrière islamique une coopération
militaires très étroites et je le répète
absolument indispensable avec chaque
état de la région
j'invite monsieur le ministre à défendre
à s'y rendre dès que possible et souvent
qu'il ne pourra générer la confiance
qu'en démontrant l'intérêt de la france
par sa présence renouvelée dans ses
territoires et en développement
ses relations personnelles avec ses
homologues de même une coordination
étroite avec la diplomatie russe qui
connaît l'afghanistan depuis des siècles
pacifiquement ou militairement doit être
renforcée mettant en place la
coopération étroite prévues par ce
traité
malgré celui ci serait très apparaîtra
toutefois comme une victoire des
salafistes une revanche d'al qaïda sur
le monde occidental chrétiens et sera
exploité comme tel son incidence sur
l'ensemble du monde musulman sont les
grands équilibres régionaux en
particulier au moyen-orient va
vraisemblablement perturbé fortement une
vaste zone stratégique très instable je
serais heureux d'entendre les actions
diplomatiques que vous entendez menées
pour éviter que ce qui est notre échec
soit exploité comme un triomphe pas nos
adversaires
le moment est venu pour les afghans de
prendre leur destin en main on
l'espérait
on l'attendait et on le redoutait à la
fois la conférence de tokyo du 8 juillet
a promis des fonds internationaux à
hauteur de 16 milliards de dollars d'ici
c'est considérable pour ont-ils vraiment
être utilisées par ce pays
l'afghanistan est défini comme un pont
terrestre un rond-point de l'asie les
etats-unis auront élaboré leur vision de
la nouvelle route de la soie en juillet
2011 dont l'afghanistan est le coeur
soyons tous convaincus que la stabilité
de la région est liée à celle de
l'afghanistan
le président de république a dit avec
beaucoup de justesse et d'émotion à nos
soldats dans chaque ligne de notre tt
d'amitié avec l'afghanistan dans chaque
action de coopération programmées à
travers cinq enfants qui apprendra notre
langue
il subsistera quelque chose de votre
courage
quelque chose de votre humanité quelque
chose aussi de la vie de nos camarades
tombés au combat
à nous d'être aux côtés de nos amis
afghans avec les mots du voyageur de
minuit de maquereaux vigilance a mis ce
chemin qui existe à peine qui peut être
n'existe pas et le bon le seul celui de
la liberté
prenez le le groupe ucr votre à ce texte
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur andré gattolin pour le groupe
écologiste
ça va en bray
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le rapporteur
et président de la commission mes chers
collègues nous devons aujourd'hui nous
prononcer sur le projet de loi
autorisant la ratification du traité
d'amitié et de coopération entre la
république française et la république
islamique d'afghanistan
cet accord est l'aboutissement d'un
processus relativement rapide qui a
débuté à l'occasion du détriment du
départ lors du déplacement du président
sarkozy
à kaboul le 12 juillet 2011 un projet de
traité a été présenté par le ministre
d'état ministre des affaires étrangères
et européennes à son homologue afghan
lors de sa visite à paris le 26 octobre
dernier
les négociations n'ont rencontré aucune
difficulté majeure et ont permis
d'aboutir à un accord sur l'ensemble du
texte le 3 janvier 2012
le traité a donc été signé le 27 janvier
2012 par nos deux pays
le programme de coopération quinquennal
qui complète le traité a été paraphée le
jour même par les ambassadeurs de france
et d'afghanistan
ce nouveau traité entend ainsi
rationaliser le cadre juridique de
l'ensemble des relations franco-afghanes
en regroupant en un seul instrument les
différents volets de notre coopération
d'après l'article 13 sont entrées en
vigueur entraînera l'abrogation de
l'accord de coopération culturelle et
technique entre le gouvernement de la
république française et le gouvernement
du royaume d'afghanistan du 21 août 1966
qui constituait jusqu'à présent
effectivement lépine dorsale de la
coopération entre nos deux pays la
france engagées sur le théâtre des
opérations afghan depuis 2001 entend
dorénavant modifier la nature de son
engagement
parallèlement au retrait progressif de
ses forces combattantes
ce traité marque donc le passage d'une
vision principalement axée sur une des
marches militaires à une conception
beaucoup plus marquée par une approche
civile l'afghanistan s'efforcent
désormais de s'inscrire dans une
certaine normalité
au niveau de la vie internationale en
témoigne notamment la conclusion
partenariats avec d'autres états dont
l'inde partenariat signé en octobre 2011
où les états unis partenariat
actuellement en préparation
le pays tente de se relever d'une
situation sécuritaire particulièrement
chaotique depuis une intervention
soviétique de 1979
la stabilité intérieure reste plus que
jamais un sujet de préoccupation
carrefour de l'asie
l'afghanistan a entretenue tout au long
de son histoire tumultueuse des rapports
tourmentée avec le monde extérieur
puisqu'elle a connu à deux mètres un peu
reprise la présence de forces étrangères
sur son sol qu'il s'agisse des
britanniques de 1840 à 1919 des
soviétiques de 1979 à 1989 ou plus
récemment est encore actuellement celle
de la coalition internationale de 49
pays depuis 2001 dont la france la mise
en place et la pérennisation d'un état
de droit représentent des défis majeurs
de l'afghanistan en effet la viabilité
d'un pays dépend avant tout de la
robustesse de ses institutions
dans cette optique comme décrit dans
l'article 1
le traité d'amitié se dote d'un double
objectif d'abord perpétuer les liens
d'amitié de paix de solidarité qui
unissent les deux pays et également
d'établir des programmes quinquennaux de
coopération dans des domaines très
variés sécurité justice démocratie
agriculture éducation sont et
archéologie et culture infrastructures
ressources minières minière est
également formation des cadres civils
composé de 13 articles se prêtait
s'efforce de couvrir les domaines
administratif sécuritaires économiques
et sociaux et financiers donc l'article
2 est un article important parce qu'il
prévoit effectivement la création de
trois commissions mixtes autonome
la commission pour le suivi des
programmes de coopération une commission
politico militaire et une commission de
sécurité intérieure
l'article 3 donc pour aller brièvement
relève de la sécurité défense l'article
4 la coopération agricole
loppement du monde rural l'article 5
couve un aspect très important qui est
celui de la coopération dans le domaine
sanitaire notamment l'objectif de
réduire le taux de mortalité maternelle
et infantile et favoriser l'accès aux
soins les articles 6 et 7
traite de la coopération en matière
d'éducation d'enseignement supérieur et
des échanges culturels avec l'objectif
de protéger et mettre en valeur le
patrimoine archéologique historique et
artistique de l'afghanistan l'article
lui puis s'intéresse particulièrement à
la gouvernance démocratique en insistant
en particulier sur la protection des
droits des femmes et leur accès à la
justice
les articles 9 et 10 portent sur le
développement des infrastructures
afghanes sur les questions économiques
financières et commerciales
quant aux trois derniers articles ils
sont surtout d'ordre administratif
l'article auront streit des dispositions
fiscales se rapportant aux personnels
français qui participent à la relation
bilatérale
l'article 12 traite des questions dix
minutes est relative au personnel
coopérants et l'article 13 donc nous
l'avons vu précédemment signifie
l'entrée en vigueur que l'entrée en
vigueur du traité abrogera les
instruments juridiques qui ont
précédemment exister c'est à dire
l'accord de coopération culturelle et
technique et ses annexes entre le
gouvernement de la république française
et gouvernement du royaume d'afghanistan
qui date est donc de 1966 en tant
qu'écologiste je me félicite de l'
inflexion clairement civile que porte ce
traité en effet l'établissement et le
développement d'un état de droit
légitime et efficace représentent les
conditions indispensables à
l'épanouissement d'une société civile
apaisée en afghanistan une réponse
purement militaire ne peut être viable à
long terme
si on souhaite voir naître un
afghanistan plus démocratique et plus
sûr en revanche je note l'absence d'un
volet environnemental dans ce traité ce
que je trouve fort dommageable vu
l'impact écologique néfastes que les
conflits successifs
on lui sur l'afghanistan voilà donc pour
les discussions autour de cet article
unique qui consacre l'évolution du
soutien de la france à l'afghanistan
d'une dominante militaire à une
dominante civile prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
le journal de 22 heures présentée par
pierre henri gergonne vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours retrouver la séance sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne après midi sur les chaînes
parlementaires